Super Saiyan 2 Goku would get absolutely
instantly curb stomped by kidboo and it
would look a little something like
this now I know what you're thinking but
I literally watched the entire episode
of Goku going toe-to-toe with kid bu let
me ruin your entire day for you real
quick that entire episode is filler an
anime only invention now don't get me
wrong the episode is extremely sick
Studio cockpit rolled out and delivered
maybe the most iconic fight scene of the
entire series but in the original story
Goku immediately goes Super Saiyan 3
before fighting kidu and like of course
he does because Super Saiyan 2 Vegeta
got instantly and completely annihilated
when he fought Buu do we really think
that Goku somehow got twice as strong as
Vegeta in between their last fight no of
course not it just doesn't make sense
for either of them to keep up with Buu
at Super Saiyan 2 but the F fight was
sick so worth the trade-off for the
added confusion Maybe